[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour soyez les
bienvenus vous êtes sur le plateau dès
maintenant l'émission qui revient
toujours avec plaisir et toujours avec
vous sur l'actualité politique de la
semaine vous connaissez le principe
hashtag et maintenant si vous souhaitez
réagir aujourd'hui autour de cette table
des invités pour qui la politique n'a
aucun secret ils sont très intelligents
ils sont affûtés c'est un peu un plateau
de gala que nous avons aujourd'hui
puisque nous avons Jonathan boucher
Petersen bonjour éditorialiste politique
à Libération merci d'être avec nous
Rachel kan bonjour vous êtes écrivain et
juriste vous avez publié une partie de
campagne aux éditions de l'Observatoire
merci d'être sur ce plateau Christophe
Bourseiller bonjour bonjour écrivain
historien je renvoie votre dernier livre
publié aux éditions Perrin il appelait
monsieur Hitler l'histoire méconnue des
nazis français et Eugénie Bastié bonjour
journaliste au Figaro votre dernier
livre La guerre des idées enquêtes au
cœur de lettinigancia française c'est
chez Robert Lafont dans cette émission
on se demandera ce qu'il reste Derrick
Zem un an après la création de ce parc
de son parti on se penchera sur la
délicate question de la fin de vie et
sur les projets du gouvernement en
matière d'immigration et puis et puis on
se demandera si les méchants sont en
train de gagner la bataille des idées à
travers le monde si j'ai une pink
Poutine R22 anéantie démocratique point
d'interrogation la séance est ouvert
merci président l'archet mais d'abord
profitons de l'électricité qui nous
reste encore sur Public Sénat pour
revenir sur la gestion du gouvernement
en matière de transport et d'énergie il
y aura-t-il des trains à Noël au nom de
l'électricité en janvier autant de
questions qui ont rythmé ces derniers
jours pour ce qui concerne l'électricité
pas toujours facile facile de suivre la
ligne de l'exécutif d'une semaine à
l'autre écouter ce pourrait que cette
année et je veille ici à l'usage du
conditionnel la production et la demande
en électricité ne soit pas totalement
alignée certains jours de grand froid et
si nous n'adaptons pas lorsque nous y
sommes appelés certaines de nos
habitudes de consommation au moment les
plus critiques nous sommes en lien
permanents avec les ARS et les agences
régionales de santé ainsi que les
préfectures qui nous signale et
identifie ces personnes-là qui ont
respirateur qui sont avec un équipement
à la maison importante
ils sont éventuellement délestables ces
personnes-là ils sont non prioritaires
si je peux me permettre de le dire ainsi
ce débat est absurde
étape sur le rôle des autorités
publiques des entreprises publiques ça
n'est pas de transférer la peur ni de
gouverner par la peur stop à tout ça
nous sommes un grand pays on a un grand
modèle énergétique nous allons tenir cet
hiver malgré la guerre et donc je
demande à chacun de faire son travail
Jonathan vous comprenez quoi cette
séquence
on entend le porte-parole des nudisme
donc quelqu'un dans le métier de parler
et de transmettre un message qui soit
pas juste une source de crise donc
dans la séquence c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué parce que de fait il y a des
facteurs qui étaient pas prévisibles on
peut comprendre qu'il y a une forme de
situation exceptionnelle en même temps
il y a une communication qui est
absolument erratique enfin on a
l'impression de se retrouver au pire
heures du covid qui était quand même
quelque chose d'un peu plus complexe à
gérer donc voilà je pense que ce qui
crée effectivement de l'insécurité ou de
l'inquiétude c'est d'abord l'absence de
discours clair d'une parole un peu
construite en expliquant ce que sont les
difficultés ce que sont les solutions
la problématique après c'est dû aussi un
fantasme français de cette idée que
l'énergie c'était une fierté l'énergie
c'était une solidité et qui rien ne
pouvait venir j'allais dire compliquer
les choses là il y a une dépendance
quand même aux énergies fossiles qui
n'était pas quelque chose qui était
absolument intégré dans le modèle en
gros c'était le nucléaire envers et
contre tout comme une espèce de source
de puissance un dépassable et un chemin
vers les énergies renouvelables
exécutif Eugénie tout à fait et moi je
enfin ce qui est ce qui est frappant
c'est
en même temps d'Emmanuel Macron et cette
espèce de manque de clarté c'est à dire
que c'était il était premier à la fin de
l'été à nous faire un discours
souvenez-vous crépusculaire sur la fin
de l'abondance et si c'était pas joué
sur la peur je sais pas ce que ce que ça
veut dire il était aussi très très
inquiet lui-même et maintenant il me dit
non rassurez-vous tout va bien se passer
moi je regrette simplement qui est pas
eu un mea culpa de la part du président
de la République sur son revirement sur
le nucléaire parce que en fait en
l'espace de quelques mois il a
complètement changé son fusil d'épaule
et il me dit maintenant que le nucléaire
c'est formidable qu'on va relancer le
nucléaire et qu'il a toujours pensé
ainsi alors que c'est lui qui c'est sous
son quinquennat qui a été fermé acté la
fermeture de Fessenheim
c'est quand même parce que oui parce que
c'est pas du tout à la hauteurs
éoliennes et le soleil nous aideraient
particulièrement en ce moment où il y a
pas de vent il y a pas de soleil
sur cette séquence par contre sur les
sur les mains sur les sur les centres
nucléaires on paye aussi un effet du
covid parce que la maintenance a été
stoppé pendant le covid des centrales
nucléaires quel pays quel autre pays au
monde a stoppé la maintenance des
centrales nucléaires pendant que le
gouvernement et à gérer cette séquence
sera selon la pression voilà que le
gouvernement n'avait pas anticipé
l'inquiétude que ça allait susciter chez
les Français on sait qu'on est dans une
période et le covid ou la montrer
grandement que on demande aux politiques
d'anticiper l'imprévisible covid et même
sur nos fondamentaux même sur la laïcité
prévisible non mais
sur la laïcité on se on se doutait pas
que ça allait être mise en question
comme ça dans nos écoles ensuite c'est
vrai que il y a peut-être un manque de
pédagogie et moi qui me suis attachée
dans les campagnes électorales et dans
les cabinets politiques à la question
des cellules de crise c'est vrai qu'on a
quand même un enjeu dans ces fameux
cellules de crise qui est cette clarté
pédagogique par rapport
aussi aux citoyens et c'est vrai que
d'un autre côté lorsque l'état anticipe
on dit qu'il fait peur lorsqu'il
n'anticipe pas on dit qu'il est
responsable donc il faut un petit peu
savoir est-ce que la colère d'Emmanuel
Macron a permis de clarifier les choses
je pense pour compléter ou répondre à ce
que dire à quelqu'un que il me semble
qu'on pouvait anticiper l'hiver je crois
pas que l'hiver ça soit un signe noir au
sens de l'événement totalement inattendu
qui nous tombe dessus par hasard comme
le covid effectivement ou la guerre du
crâne je crois que dans ce cas présent
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un gouvernement
qui n'est pas capable de gérer les
infrastructures de les mettre en l'état
j'ai l'impression que la France est dans
un processus de déclin terrible si on en
est là et c'est quelque part c'est
intéressant parce que quelque part ça
crédibilise le discours des
collapsologues qui vous disent que tout
va s'écrouler à partir de 2030 et quand
on voit la fragilité de nos
infrastructures il suffit qu'il neige un
peu pour que plus rien ne fonctionne il
suffit qu'il y ait un conflit et qu'on
s'aperçoit à mon Dieu on n'a pas géré
les stocks énergétiques à mon Dieu et
tout du coup on aurait plus
d'électricité là je crois qu'on peut
vraiment s'inquiéter se dire
qu'effectivement peut-être que un jour
tout va s'écrouler parce que justement
il y aura un tel banque de
d'anticipation de la part de nos
gouvernants on est tellement la barre
sur les sondages le nez sur les sondages
que tout devient possible pour le
rappelle quand même d'Emmanuel Macron
qui le 14 juillet parlait déjà de
délestage qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
entre-temps ce mot délestage abject ça
veut dire coupure plutôt que de dire
coupure on dit délestage c'est n'importe
quoi il y a là quelque chose de ce
discours monstrueux pour faire passer
l'austérité c'est affreux non mais moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quand même
une forme de de gourmandise au chaos
quoi il sert pour l'instant rien passé
et on a l'impression que tout le monde
en force son cheval en disant c'est la
preuve du déclin c'est la preuve que la
France n'est plus la France c'est enfin
cette espèce d'affaissement pour
l'instant on est dans une situation qui
sur le papier et pas plus catastrophique
que celle de la plupart de nos voisins
européens et en revanche la totalité des
discours et pas du tout la même encore
une fois on tombe peut-être de plus haut
parce que derrière cette idée du
nucléaire donc on peut toujours dire
c'est le revirement d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a la source de tous les problèmes
fondamentalement il y avait des
centrales vieillissantes si elles sont
entre eux on aurait pu pleins de choses
rétrospectivement mais ça c'est plus
d'Emmanuel Macron écoutez là
ce que vous rendez compte quand même
qu'on est au 21e siècle dans la 6e
puissance mondiale et quand on est en
train de nous expliquer que on va
retourner à l'âge de pierre parce qu'on
aura plus d'électricité parce qu'il va
falloir vivre en baissant
considérablement le chauffage parce que
les Français ont pu payer la facture et
et tout cela passe crème bah moi je suis
désolé ça passe pas crème ça m'indigne
ça veut dire que nous sommes dirigés par
des incapables par des incompétents par
des imprévoyants et qu'une fois de plus
c'est pas eux qui payent les
conséquences de ça ce sont les Français
Rachel c'est de bonne guerre les
oppositions s'opposent non mais là c'est
ridicule et effectivement je vous
rejoins parfaitement sur le réel on en
est pas là du tout après
l'instrumentalisation politique pour
dire que le gouvernement est incompétent
alors en ce moment il se passe rien au
niveau de notre électricité on n'a pas
encore eu de coupure c'est pas
effectivement le chaos moi ça me ça me
heurte un peu parce que cette vengeance
sur l'anticipation elle est elle est
elle est facile de dire on aurait dû
faire si on aurait dû faire ça quand on
se retrouve confronté à une réalité
c'est facile après on parle pas non plus
des écologistes qui ont lu les rapports
du GIEC depuis un certain nombre
d'années et qui jamais ont changé leur
fusil d'épaule par rapport au nucléaire
et là pour le coup sur les questions
d'énergie on peut valoriser le en même
temps puisqu'il faut du nucléaire des
énergies renouvelables et du soleil
alors rappelons qu'il y a 19 réacteurs
nucléaires actuellement à l'arrêt sur 58
Eugénie est-ce que c'est quel est le
lien avec la guerre en Ukraine sur
l'arrêt de ces réacteurs aucun voilà
donc oui je veux bien que ce soit la
faute de la guerre en Ukraine mais là
les 19 réacteurs larissent n'est pas lié
à la guerre en Ukraine il faut le dire
c'est parce qu'il y a eu un défaut
d'anticipation on sait on a un peu
abandonné notre filière on se dit c'est
pas important il y a eu le covid
effectivement le fait que on n'aime pas
on n'a pas maintenu la maintenance
pendant le covid et maintenant on le
paye aujourd'hui et c'est d'ailleurs
fait c'est parti de tous ses effets
post-ovites on n'a pas fini de payer
cette facture de de l'immobilisme
dit quelque chose de nous parce qu'on ne
cesse d'anticiper un futur épouvantable
on a 12 a dit oh là là la récession
économique ça va être abominable en 2023
oh là là on pourra même pas payer de
chauffage ne vous chauffez pas parce que
vous n'aurez pas les moyens de payer ça
parce que les prix du chauffage vont
tripler quadrupler quintupler ça va être
la République de Weimar maintenant on
nous dit oh là là en 2023 il y aura plus
d'électricité alors qu'est-ce que ça dit
d'une espèce d'angoisse collective là il
y a un signal le faible comme on dit
assez fort qui nous a eu sur les peurs
quoi qu'on est complètement un peuple
apeuré oui
1978 hein dans ces temps heureux là pour
le coup il y a eu effectivement et parce
qu'il y a déjà eu d'énergétique et là il
y a eu un blackout très concret mais ça
c'est le temps d'avant qui était
tellement mieux juste d'un mot c'est
qu'il y a évidemment que la question
nucléaire est un sujet il n'empêche
qu'on peut pas balayer la question de la
guerre en Ukraine sur la question des
prix et en France je suis désolé on peut
dire plein de choses et moi je suis pas
le dernier à dire que ce gouvernement
est pas au niveau et notamment sur la
gestion pédagogique de ce moment-là mais
concrètement le signal prix pour
l'instant on est le seul pays en Europe
ne ressens pas donc il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est un peu antinomique
on a quasiment à l'état on a l'état le
plus protecteur et on a l'état qui est
le plus mis en cause pour son incurie
donc au bout d'un moment faut juste
choisir je comprends que l'ambition en
tout cas le refrain confortable c'est
c'est d'attaquer mais je pense qu'il
faut choisir l'angle et pas tout dire en
même temps quoi peut-on encore en France
des battre sereinement du sujet de
l'immigration c'était en tout cas l'un
des défis posés au députés cette semaine
puisqu'un débat s'envoie était organisé
mardi à l'Assemblée nationale l'occasion
pour le gouvernement de dévoiler les
grandes lignes d'une loi qui sera
présentée en début d'année prochaine
écoutez notre pays a toujours accueilli
et intégré toujours délivrer des titres
de séjour avec des périodes d'arrivée
parfois plus marquées parfois moins
soutenu
la France est et restera fidèle à sa
tradition d'asile mais il est légitime
de se poser la question de notre
politique migratoire dire qui on veut
qui on peut accueillir et qui on ne veut
pas qui on ne peut pas accueillir encore
un débat sur l'immigration Christophe
est-ce que le débat de manière générale
le débat sur les migrations en France
est un débat miné il est miné parce que
il polarise ses extrêmes c'est à dire
que je trouve que la position là pour le
coup d'Elizabeth borde relativement
sensé puisqu'elle dit l'immigration zéro
ni immigration dérégulée donc elle
appelle à une immigration raisonnable on
pourrait dire mais sa focalise tout de
suite c'est-à-dire si on dit attention
il y a trop d'immigrés on est
eren on est Zemmour on est tout ce que
vous voulez si on dit au contraire
effectivement c'est bien que certains
immigrés rentrent parce que il y a des
emplois qui ont besoin d'être
remplis enfin en quelque sorte alors à
ce moment-là on est accusé d'être pour
que toutes les vannes sous qui n'est
plus c'est pas possible débattre
sereinement
xénophobie alors que c'est la maîtrise
de notre souveraineté nos frontières qui
est un des principaux même de la
populaire la nécessité entre guillemets
une partie de la gauche contexte
conteste la nécessité enfin la
possibilité la nécessité de fermer les
frontières oui je pense ensuite je dois
contrôler l'immigration alors
fermer les frontières quoi donc en tout
cas d'avoir une maîtrise de nos
frontières fermées à 100% évidemment
qu'on peut pas dans le débat politique
qui porte ça l'idée
la fermeture des frontières avec un mur
deuxième chose moi qui me frappe dans ce
débat c'est cette espèce de de mantra
qu'on entend on entend on vient
d'entendre dans la bouche d'Élisabeth
borde comme quoi notre pays a toujours
été un pays d'immigration excusez-moi
parce que
c'est absolument faux notre pays est un
pays d'immigration depuis 1860 environ
la France n'est pas né en 1860 et en
plus autrefois c'était une immigration
de travail aujourd'hui c'est une
immigration de peuplement avec le
regroupement familial autrefois c'était
une immigration
européenne aujourd'hui c'est une
immigration extra-européenne qui pose
des problèmes d'assimilation différents
et je crois que de ne pas nommer les
choses de ne pas dire finalement nous
sommes face à un défi nouveau dans notre
histoire massif et qui et qui et qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce que nous avons vécu
dans le passé et bien ne pas vouloir
nommer ça ça fait partie du problème je
rappelle juste que depuis 1945 la France
a voté une loi sur l'immigration tous
les deux ans en moyenne Rachel
ce débat il est nécessaire aujourd'hui
le gouvernement qui rouvre effectivement
ce débat sur les migrations il y aura
une loi au début de l'année prochaine
mais est-ce qu'il est nécessaire est-ce
que c'est nécessaire de rouvrir
d'avoir un débat qui soit juste sur le
réel on ne peut pas parler d'une
immigration mais des immigrations on a
la question de droit d'asile et des
réfugiés on a la question des migration
économiques celle du travail et puis on
a la question aussi des clandestins donc
on a des immigrations qui sont des
chances et d'autres qui sont plutôt de
l'ordre de la malchance moi j'aimerais
bien renommer en fait ce sujet qui est à
l'ordre du jour une loi sur la
citoyenneté c'est à dire qu'en fait nous
ne sommes pas un peuple et effectivement
le discours qui tend à dire que nous
sommes un peuple d'immigrés c'est pas
tout à fait ça nous ne sommes pas un
peuple ethnique nous ne sommes pas un
peuple religieux nous sommes un peuple
politique qui se retrouve autour d'un
socle commun qui qui sont nos principes
fondamentaux de liberté d'égalité de
souveraineté de de laïcité etc et en
fait cet accueil là de ces personnes en
fait elle doit elles doivent épouser
notre socle commun nos fondamentaux et
notamment notre langue aussi c'est comme
ça c'est un monstre
c'est c'est plus que les questions de
migration puisqu'on voit à quel point
aujourd'hui effectivement 8 Français sur
10 estiment qu'ils ne peuvent pas parler
d'immigration librement puisque ils sont
taxés et comme vous le disiez un alors
que ce n'est pas le sujet et le problème
c'est que la gauche a abandonné cette
question là par une culpabilité très mal
placée juste je vous donne la parole
dans un instant Jonathan sur le fond le
gouvernement borne va notamment proposer
une régularisation facilité pour les
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension on va écouter Gérald
dedans qui fixe quelques critères cette
personne satisfait à un certain nombre
de critères par exemple pas de casier
judiciaire toute personne en France
qu'aurait un casier judiciaire et qui
sera étranger ne pourra pas être
régularisé et sera donc expulsé du
territoire national on veut ce qui
bossent on veut pas ce qui rapine
Jonathan j'ai l'impression que tous les
ministres de l'Intérieur veulent leur
loi immigration
c'est un débat qui se referme jamais
donc on dit toujours qu'on ne peut pas
en parler on a l'impression que la doxa
dominante moi j'ai l'impression que même
quand la gauche était au pouvoir c'était
Manuel Valls qui portait ses questions
là je peux le sentiment qu'on était sur
les frontières ouvertes aux quatre vents
et un discours qui était construit sur
autre chose que l'idée de fermeté donc
je pense qu'il y a une espèce
d'inversion du réel encore une fois
c'est
Emmanuel Macron ouais ouais 400000
rencontres par an peut-être alors le
chiffre ont toujours été contestés en
tout cas sur un flux non non mais c'est
pas si le dire non moi je dis ces
chiffres ils sont régulièrement
contestés par des gens qui connaissent
que vous et que moi donc je pense que
c'est à mon avis chacun juste aller
regarder ça a été un des débat de la
campagne présidentielle assez
régulièrement je pense qu'on est
beaucoup sur le fontaine c'est-à-dire on
a quand même 30 ans d'une d'une opinion
publique qui a pas tellement d'éléments
objectifs sur le sujet qui est chauffé à
blanc par l'idée d'invasion par l'idée
de submersion par l'idée encore une fois
c'est quand même majoritairement il y a
trois étrangers ou des migrés en France
il faut ça il faut que ça il faut
l'entendre quand on entend
régularisation on parle de quelques
milliers de personnes là dans des
métiers en tension ou jusqu'à preuve du
contraire quand les offres sont ouvertes
elles ne trouvent pas preneur et les les
les gens qui tiennent ces activités là
sont les sur les premiers à demander on
est ça c'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
je pense qu'il y a deux trucs comme à
dire le l'idée que ça va pas s'arrêter
juste parce qu'on dit fermeture des
frontières battre en brèche l'idée qu'il
y a des appels d'air parce que
soi-disant la France serait une espèce
de terre promise la France et une terre
de passage pour la majorité des immigrés
l'essentiel des migration à l'échelle du
monde se fait à l'intérieur de
l'hémisphère sud donc pour pour le coup
laisser les pays j'allais dire à qui on
dit toujours il faut qu'elles prennent
leur part de cette enjeu d'un accueille
l'immigration de façon beaucoup plus
massive donc encore une fois c'est un
sujet c'est un sujet d'inquiétude qu'il
faut entendre en revanche tout ce qui
est submersion mise en péril de la
civilisation européenne et française 70
ans effectivement qu'on légifère qu'on
fait des réformes sur l'immigration pour
toujours plus de dureté quand même un
peu le même discours que Elizabeth borne
alors pas avec les mêmes termes etc
pourquoi on en revient à une loi par an
pratiquement tous les deux ans
Christophe d'incapacité à gérer le réel
c'est-à-dire la multiplication de loi
c'est un peu comme les lois
anti-casseurs vous savez on a en France
on fait des lois anti-casseurs chaque
fois qu'il y a une manifestation en
oubliant qu'on en a fait 18 avant et
qu'on les a abrogé les unes derrière les
autres donc c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne en France par des effets
d'annonce c'est dommage gouverner sur le
long terme permettrait peut-être
justement de réguler cette ce phénomène
de l'immigration il s'agit pas de sauf
que là ça part d'un bon sentiment il
s'agit pas d'interdire l'immigration il
le réguler l'immigration c'est peut-être
ça la bonne solution on est dans un
monde marqué par un nomadisme généralisé
on peut pas faire comme si ça n'existait
pas c'est comme ça les moyens de
communication sont développés
aujourd'hui tout le monde est nomade il
y a les migrants qui arrivent en France
et les Français qui vont vivre à
l'étranger on appelle ça des expats
migrants expats c'est quand même un peu
la même chose donc si vous voulez de
c'est comme ça c'est le monde
aujourd'hui il faut donc vivre avec et
réguler mais faut arrêter de d'idéologie
je pense aussi qu'il y a un discours si
vous dites on a besoin d'immigration
c'est quel cas de dire ce que dit
ce que dit l'Union européenne l'Europe
et vieillissante on a besoin de
l'immigration vous envoyez le message
que les gens peuvent traverser la
Méditerranée qui sont devenus je pense
qu'il faut envoyer le message inverse il
faut envoyer un signal fort en disant
nous ne voulons plus d'immigration après
effectivement que le réel soit complexe
qu'il soit difficile de répondre à ces
sujets très bien mais changeons au moins
de discours il y avait un discours pour
un premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
il a fait un discours des Mureaux sur
l'islamisme où il a nommé les choses et
c'était bien dit vraiment qu'elle était
les menaces il a parlé de laïcité moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait un discours
des Mureaux de l'immigration on nomme
clairement le réel et qu'on arrête de
louvoyer et de dire en même temps
l'immigration est un défi et en même
temps on en a besoin etc sur la
citoyenneté et sur la capacité d'accueil
réel c'est-à-dire vraiment d'éducation à
cette citoyens là aujourd'hui dire oui à
tout le monde c'est d'accueillir
personne
les méchants
il y en a pas en Allemagne par exemple
c'est l'administration française qui
délivre des auqtf c'est pas judiciaires
c'est autre chose c'est administratif ça
n'existe pas dans d'autres pays donc
c'est vrai que les comparaisons en tant
que tel on a on peut pas dire si la
France est complètement à côté de la
plaque ou pas là-dessus orange dire que
c'est un sujet moi je pense que c'est un
sujet qui alimenté par beaucoup de
fantasmes ça veut pas dire qu'il faut le
traiter et encore une fois depuis 30 ans
on est dans un discours de fermeté quasi
généralisé à part Philippe Poutou à part
Philippe Poutou qui a priori n'a pas eu
le pouvoir ces dernières années
merci beaucoup les méchants sont-ils en
train de gagner la bataille des idées
c'est notre troisième thème il porte sur
la montée en puissance des dictatures et
des régimes autoritaires à travers le
monde alors certes le magazine Time a
fait de volodi mirzelinski la
personnalité de l'année mais force est
de constater que 2022 restera comme
l'année de l'offensive russe en Ukraine
ou encore du durcissement du régime
totalitaire chinois deux pays qui ont
l'Occident dans le viseur écoutez
face à un monde une époque et une
histoire en constante évolution
la Chine est prête à faire des efforts
avec la Russie pour assumer le rôle de
grande puissance
et jouer un rôle de guide pour apporter
stabilité et énergie positive dans un
monde secoué par les troubles sociaux
il y a un autre Occident agressif
cosmopolite néo-colonial qui sert
d'outils aux élites néolibéral c'est le
diktat de cet Occident que la Russie
bien sûr nos tolérera jamais
écouté c'est plus compliqué que ça
d'abord on peut pas tout mettre dans le
même sac c'est vous pouvez pas mettre
par exemple la Hongrie de Victor urbaine
dans le même sac que la Corée du Nord on
efface la des régimes différents de
nature différente vous avez des régimes
totalitaires vous avez des régimes
néocommunistes comme la Chine vous avez
des régimes autoritaires comme la Russie
et puis vous avez un phénomène beaucoup
plus inquiétant peut-être moi je trouve
c'est ce qu'on appelle les démocraties
libéral pourquoi parce que quand on dit
qu'il y a une montée des populistes une
montée des démocraties dites il
libérales en fait la bonté des
populistes ça provient de quoi de la
crise de la démocratie ça veut dire que
nos démocraties à nous ne sont pas
parfaites ça veut dire que nos
démocraties est-ce que c'est pas devenu
des oligarchies est-ce qu'au fond on
ferait pas mieux de s'interroger
nous-mêmes sur la nature de notre
système qu'on défend avec tant de
convictions
démocratie libérale au sens de
Tocqueville démocratie libérale au sens
où les libertés circulent est-ce que
cette démocratie là elle n'est pas en
crise profondément en crise moi je crois
que c'est l'élitisme qu'on a vécu ces
dernières années qui explique le
populisme je pense que le populisme
n'est pas arrivé ex nihilo le populisme
il est né de l'attitude des élites qui
ont cru passer par-dessus le peuple qui
sont dit on peut pas on peut se passer
de la démocratie on peut créer des
technostructures anarchiques et je crois
que tout est là alors donc il faut
vraiment que nous sur l'opposition
est-ce qu'on est d'accord sur ce plateau
il y a un véhicule ou pas des
démocraties dans le monde absolument
mais encore une fois je pense qu'il faut
distinguer ce qu'on appelle les leaders
populistes et les régimes autoritaires
Poutine soit un populiste par exemple a
priori en revanche c'est pas exactement
le même schéma qu'un bolsonaro ou qu'un
Trump ou que encore avec dans un autre
registre un Boris Johnson ce qui est sûr
c'est que les démocraties sont fatiguées
ça c'est absolument un indéniable la
demande d'État elle est quand même aussi
forte donc qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière
autorité est-ce que c'est autoritarisme
homme providentiel restriction des
libertés ou est-ce que c'est puissance
publique au sens puissance donc capacité
à répondre aux enjeux à qui pour
répondre aux inquiétudes à répondre aux
urgences qu'elles soient sociale qu'elle
soit partage de la richesse qu'elle soit
écologique qu'elle soit régalien aussi
c'est pas du tout un sujet mineur mais
ça peut pas être exclusif de la
puissance publique sinon ça s'apparente
globalement une restriction des libertés
et encore une fois je rappelle qu'il y a
quelques années dans une partie de une
bonne partie de l'extrême droite de la
droite le modèle de l'homme fort le
modèle de la défense de la utilisation
c'était Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui
c'est le symbole du nationalisme et de
l'impérialisme on en reparlera
un double rapport je vais vous montrer
un double rapport et je vous fais réagir
ensuite génial rapport en date de
novembre qui est publié par l'Institut
idéal en situation
et l'assistance électorale et un autre
rapport de l'institutionédois videm sur
les 100k de démocratiques compte
aujourd'hui la planète 48 sont
aujourd'hui menacés par un recul des
libertés un quart de l'humanité vis sous
une dictature tandis que le groupe des
autocraties compte aujourd'hui 60 pays
soit 44% de la population mondiale le
génie comment vous interprétez ça est-ce
que une fatigue de la démocratie
libérale dans le monde je crois qu'en
tout cas on vit la fin d'une forme
d'utopique était de penser que la
démocratie allait s'installer
universellement que le modèle
occidental allait pouvoir s'implanter
comme ça et que signifie l'eau dans tous
les pays du monde alors que il nous a
demandé nous en Occident et en Europe
c'est le fruit de guerre ça a été le
fruit de guerre civile d'un long
mûrissement démocratique d'une conquête
de droit qui était très très longue et
qui on a qu'on n'est pas devenu du jour
au lendemain avec démocratie et je crois
qu'il y a eu un peu une espèce
d'illusion que ce modèle allait se
répandre et qu'elle allait devenir
universelle on voit que ce n'est pas le
cas que que par contre
je pense que si la démocratie n'est pas
un modèle universel la liberté le désir
de liberté est universel il est ancré
dans le cœur de l'homme et on le voit
que ce soit les Chinois qui protestent
contre le covid les Iraniennes qui
veulent retirer leur voile ou les Russes
qui demandent la liberté d'expression le
désir de liberté il est universel je
pense que un régime purement autoritaire
qui ne donne pas de liberté à sa
population ne peut pas en tout cas enfin
survivra difficilement dans le temps
est-ce que c'est forcément il va devenir
une démocratie dans le sens libéral du
terme je ne pense pas mais une pure une
pure autocratie ne peut pas durer de la
même manière en fait il y a un retour de
balancier c'est à dire que en Occident
nous sommes dans un régime qui accorde
énormément de place aux libertés
individuelles et il y a une demande de
retour de l'autorité et dans ces régimes
autocratiques il y a une demande de
liberté on a vu ces chiffres Rachel
comment vous les interprétez la
démocratie ne fait plus rêver entre
guillemets c'est un peu ce que je
comprends de ce qui vient de dire
Eugénie je partage tout à fait ce qui a
été dit autour de la table en fait c'est
comme si il y avait une ambiance de
fascination
sur l'autoritarisme en réalité et on le
sent même dans nos pays
occidentaux moi je suis frappé parce que
j'ai entendu de Vladimir Poutine qui a
tient un discours décolonial donc qui se
conjugue aussi avec des dogmes qui et
alors mais oui mais là c'était surtout
comme un impérialisme
c'est que ça se conjugue avec des
discours qui sont tenus ici sur le
décolonialisme donc c'est ça qui est
assez étonnant c'est à dire qu'on a
envie enfin on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons envie
d'autoritarisme finalement pour ne plus
penser par nous-mêmes on était sur le
réel tout à l'heure mais pour avoir des
règles extrêmement fortes extrêmement
figées et on retrouve très précisément
ce qui avait écrit toc ville à l'époque
de la démocratie en Amérique avec trop
d'égalitar et ben tu finalement cette
démocratie et on est cette perte de
repères finalement appelle à des
autocraties Christophe moi je pensais
qu'après la chute du mur de Berlin ça y
est la démocratie libérale elle est
triompher il y a eu ce rêve un moment
donné il y a eu un état de grâce à ces
fugitif après la chute du mur de Berlin
dans les années
1990 mais si vous regardez les sondages
aujourd'hui en France vous voyez que les
gens ils sont en demande principalement
non pas de démocratie mais de sécurité
alors ils demandent la sécurité
policière en disant oh là là il y a la
délinquance on a peur et puis demande la
sécurité sociale en disant l'État que
l'État me protège que l'État fait en
sorte que j'ai ma retraite et qu'on ne
me retire pas mes retraites etc etc donc
il y a un plutôt une demande aujourd'hui
d'autorité et de sécurité et pourtant je
crois qu'il faut aller encore un tout
petit peu plus loin je crois que le
peuple français est quand même attaché à
la démocratie vous savez on l'a vu avec
les gilets jaunes parce que les gilets
jaunes étaient un peu foutra qu'il y
avait de tout dans ce mouvement mais il
y avait aussi le désir du Rick le un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
qu'est-ce que c'était d'autre le RICS
mantra-duric si ce n'est de dire
réveiller la démocratie voyez et
regardez les dernières élections c'est
assez intéressant parce qu'en fait au
second tour de la présidentielle Macron
est élu parce que les Français disent on
n'a pas envie de vivre à un moment
populiste au fond et puis aller
législatives ils disent mais quand même
Macron on n'a pas envie non plus qu'il a
de qu'il applique un programme par trop
d'austérité par trop libéral qui risque
de de mettre un mal nos retraites etc et
donc ils élisent une chambre qui en
quelque sorte enlève les pleins pouvoirs
à Macron donc il y a quand même une
sorte de d'expression démocratique qui
reste vivante vous voyez c'est donc la
démocratie en France Jonathan vous êtes
d'accord ah oui moi je pense que ça
reste quand même l'horizon le plus
souhaité après que des moments en plus
de crise ou qui crée quand même beaucoup
d'incertitudes face c'est souvent dans
ces moments là quand même qu'il y a une
espèce de en disant que le tout tout la
démocratie c'est parfois c'est plus long
aussi la démocratie c'est plus compliqué
c'est sûr que le le chemin de la
providentiel qui vient tout imposer d'en
haut à quelque chose de rassurant un
certain moment mais créer des
abîme quand même la société je pense que
la démocratie ça reste quand même
quelque chose qui quand on voit Trump
bolsonaro Johnson par exemple c'est
leader populiste
quand on s'est retrouvé face à la crise
du covid on s'est rendu compte que ils
étaient quand même largement à côté de
la plaque et ils ont les uns et les
autres étaient balayés je pense que la
question que le modèle occidental de
façon un peu messianique pense pouvoir
imposer cette espèce d'indépassable dans
le monde entier ça c'est quand même fait
aussi sur une captation de richesse qui
apparu le le cocktail très très sexy
pour bien dépays après moi je suis pas
complètement infataliste je pense
qu'effectivement le demande de liberté
elle est quelque chose d'absolument
universel après ce que le modèle
occidental a vocation à être j'allais
dire à s'imposer partout dans le monde
non en revanche nous de se dire que la
démocratie est pas un acquis et qu'il
faut la rendre un peu plus concrète un
peu plus vivifiante et un peu moins
capté par ce que j'ai mis à peine une
autocratie ou en tout cas un club et on
se rend compte que les Français ils ont
surtout le sentiment d'être de la
démocratie plutôt que de se dire que la
démocratie est un danger quoi
je suis pas sûr que oui mais en fait je
pense que
pour eux pour pour eux ce sont nous les
méchants et je dis pas qu'il faut être
relativiste mais je pense que c'est
certain discours un peu moralisateur
peut-être aussi très mal perçu
atlantique du magazine Atlantique on va
le voir
pour justifier du mal vous savez c'est
basé évidemment
on va jouer un petit peu si vous voulez
si vous voulez bien les amis on passe à
la rubrique fake news ou pas je vous
soumets une info ou quelque chose qui
ressemble à une info et vous me dites si
c'est une vraie information ou si c'est
une fake news alors en France Jonathan
parce que je sais que vous êtes un
expert en France une ville persiste à
interdire l'atterrissage de soucoupe
volante un maire a pris un arrêté qui
refuse à ces engins de se poser sur le
territoire de la commune tout aéronef
qui atterrira dans la zone sera
immédiatement mis la fourrière selon le
texte en question fake news ou pas c'est
vrai
c'est la ville d'Arès au bord du bassin
d'Arcachon
[Rires]
qui a été transformé en parking parce
que vous apprenez quelque chose voilà
parce que c'est une vraie information
effectivement la ville de
Châteauneuf-du-Pape dans le Vaucluse
c'est un arrêté qui date de 1954 au
sujet le grand Gilbert Montagné le très
grand Gilbert Montagné qui suit de près
la coupe du monde de foot il a même
écrit une chanson pour les Bleus et plus
particulièrement pour Kylian Mbappé je
vous soumets les paroles je vais pas la
chanter mais je vous soumets les paroles
Killian tout début de son magnifique en
équipe de France était magique tu nous
fais tellement rêver depuis longtemps
Jonathan fake news ou pas vous avez
inventé les paroles ça le principe
Rachel aussi moi je l'ai pas entendu
c'est vrai on va l'écouter on va écouter
Gilbert Montagné
[Musique]
voilà l'avantage de cette chanson c'est
qu'elle va vous rester dans la tête
pendant les 48 prochaines heures coupe
du coup du monde toujours l'Arabie
Saoudite est encore sur son petit nuage
depuis sa victoire contre l'Argentine en
face de groupe le roi Salman avait déjà
vous le savez décréter un jour férié
après cette victoire historique mais il
va encore plus loin puisqu'il vient de
décréter le 22 novembre comme un jour
sans lapidation vin de novembre date du
match Argentine Arabie Saoudite est-ce
que c'est une vraie information ça ne
fait pas rire Jonathan mais c'est une
fausse information évidemment c'est le
gorafi aller plus sérieux beaucoup
beaucoup plus service public beaucoup
plus sérieux pourra-t-on bientôt choisir
sa mort ce vendredi une convention
citoyenne a été lancée par Emmanuel
Macron 150 français tirés au sort vont
débat jusqu'au printemps de la délicate
question de la fin de vie et ensuite et
ensuite suspense c'est le gouvernement
ne s'est engagé sur aucune réforme mais
les associations attendent beaucoup de
ce débat écoutez ça fait 20 ans qu'on a
des lois sur la fin de vie donc ça on le
prend le temps en France des conventions
il y en a déjà les commissions il y en a
déjà eu j'avais été additionné mon 2018
par une convention citoyenne qui s'était
auto saisie de la question de la fin de
vie avec les mêmes conclusions il faut
développer massivement les soins
palliatifs et il faut légaliser la
directive à mourir donc moi je dis
chiche c'est Emmanuel Macron nouvelle
convention allons au bout ça va
permettre de parler du sujet de la fin
de vie ça va permettre de parler des
soins palliatifs ça permet de parler des
législations à l'étranger donc ça au
moins se mérite là voilà pour peser le
débat je vous rappelle le régime actuel
la loi klace Leonetti de 2016 interdit
le tanazi et le suicide assisté mais
autorise la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès donc
l'endormissement jusqu'au décès et une
éventuelle réforme porterait porterait
sur l'autorisation du suicide assisté le
suicide assisté qui consiste à fournir
les moyens nécessaires à une personne
pour déclencher sa propre mort et
l'euthanasie qui consiste à faire mourir
quelqu'un intentionnellement pour lui
éviter des souffrances Christophe sur le
timing de l'ouverture de ce débat
comment vous l'expliquez pourquoi
maintenant est-ce que c'est une urgence
j'imagine que on veut nous divertir un
petit peu nous on parle trop de
l'Ukraine on parle trop des coupures des
délaissages pardon on parle trop de ces
sujets là donc ils veulent nous changer
les idées et nous emmener vers une sorte
de jeu où on va parler de du droit de
mourir ce qui est un débat métaphysique
anciens ah oui c'est la typique
typiquement une diversion il y a
peut-être une grève qui se profile à la
SNCF donc c'est le moment de parler
d'autre chose donc je pense qu'on est
plutôt d'en parler selon vous
personnellement je soutiens Jean-Luc
Godard donc c'est les choses sont
claires moi je suis pour le droit de
mourir dans la dignité je suis pour le
recours au suicide assisté si on le
souhaite
on ira en Suisse c'est pas la question
mais disons personne en ce qui me
concerne le débat est déjà classé et en
plus j'ai l'impression qu'en France il y
a toujours un peu une espèce de il y a
blabla officiel et la réalité du terrain
c'est-à-dire que quand les gens sont
très malades on les aide quand même
enfin voyez il y a quelque chose d'assez
ambigu dans le quotidien de l'hôpital ce
qui fait que on est vraiment la face à
une espèce de convention gadget un peu
peut-être même encore un peu plus gadget
que la Convention sur le climat c'est
dire on va en parler et qui risque de
déboucher sur pas grand chose comme
d'habitude génie c'est universion non
j'avais pas que c'est une version parce
que c'est un sujet important mais je
pense que en effet on est on sait comme
sur l'immigration on a une loi tous les
deux ans vous disiez sur l'immigration
on a une loi aussi sur la fin de vie
régulièrement comme si finalement la
mécanique sociétale exigeait un
perpétuellement et un perpétuel
adaptation de nos lois au désir
individuel et ce sera jamais fini parce
que si on l'égalise le tanazi certains
vous diront par exemple les malades
d'Alzheimer qui sont probablement pas
dans la loi et bien demain il y aura une
nouvelle loi qui devrait être prise et
c'est un cycle infini moi je trouve
qu'on avait trouvé avec la loi Leonetti
une forme d'équilibre qui était
difficile à trouver entre le nom à
l'acharnement thérapeutique la sédation
aussi profonde en fin de vie cette loi
n'est pas appliquée parce que
effectivement palatiques ne sont pas
assez développés ce qui est ce que
prévoyait la loi et je trouve que dans
un contexte où notre système de santé
est en crise où les soins palliatifs ne
sont pas développées proposer la fin de
vie dans ce contexte là et bien ça peut
pousser effectivement une sorte de
pression sociale qui peut pousser
certaines personnes à choisir la fin de
vie parce qu'elles sont un poids pour
leurs proches parce que il n'y a pas
assez de de soins palliatifs pour les
accompagner etc donc je suis très
méfiante je pense qu'il faut avancer
avec énormément de prudence sur ce sujet
et que voilà l'idée d'un d'un souffle de
l'histoire d'un vent du progrès qui
rendrait cette évolution inéluctable et
bien ce n'est pas un argument valable on
va parler de la méthode si vous voulez
bien aussi parce que deux invités sont
pas d'accord sur la question de la
méthode c'est un super Dubel qu'on a sur
ce plateau d'un côté c'est Jonathan de
l'autre c'est Rachel est-ce que quelque
chose peut vraiment ressortir de cette
convention cette citoyenne effectivement
il y a une autre convention qui était
dédiée au climat cette fois-ci c'est sur
la fin de vie vous avez 45 secondes
chacun Jonathan vous allez commencer
pour vous oui quelque chose peut
ressortir de cette convention citoyenne
non mais sans être absolument Béa
évidemment l'expérience de la convention
citoyenne précédente pousse pas à
l'optimisme après moi je pense que c'est
un outil parmi d'autres c'est à dire
qu'il y a la convention citoyenne qui
existe qui a un lieu qui peut permettre
de créer un débat un peu plus éclairé
qu'effectivement que les positions un
peu idéologiques ou mal informés que les
uns et les autres peuvent avoir ce que
c'est un sujet qui évidemment nous
concerne tous auquel on est confronté
dans la sphère familiale ou amicale donc
je pense que cet outil sans en faire la
panacée sans en faire le remplacement de
quoi que ce soit mais bien
potentiellement enrichir le débat je
pense pas que ce soit une diversion
parce que c'est un engagement de
campagne et simplement le calendrier
était prévu il se trouve que ça vient à
ce moment-là donc on peut l'interpréter
comme on veut mais c'était juste attendu
donc encore une fois j'allais dire
lucidité sur le fait que la convention
citoyenne n'a pas vocation à tout régler
on sent quand même une prudence du
gouvernement donc oui ça sert à esquiver
des décisions un peu verticales mais je
pense que tout ce qui peut contribuer à
éclairer le débat sans l'hystériser
moi j'ai une syntaxe donc je te dis
d'abord ma phrase Rachel c'est un duo
c'est un duel vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec Jonathan vous avez 45 secondes
parce que franchement non sur la
convention citoyenne moi je suis très
adoucissante parce que ça fait 20 ans
qu'on a c'est concertations en plus
ajouter convention citoyenne démocratie
participative démocratie représentative
on a des députés on a un gouvernement on
a aussi en parallèle une consultation
des experts des médecins des personnes
qui sont dans les milieux vraiment
proches en fait des malades et de ces
situations
dramatiques donc je me dis une
convention encore pourquoi comment
jusqu'où avec qui je sais qu'il y avait
cette volonté d'être dans une
représentation de la diversité sauf
qu'en fait très concrètement ça se passe
sur des week-ends les gens des DOM-TOM
par exemple ne peuvent pas venir
faire la consultation citoyenne moi ça
me met un peu mal à l'aise merci
Christophe vous pouvez nous trancher
peut-être ce débat est-ce que la méthode
peut-être déjà sur la méthode qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de la cette convention
cette seconde convention citoyenne
organisée par Emmanuel Macron est-ce
qu'on a besoin encore de consulter
effectivement on en parle beaucoup il y
a eu des travaux Parlement est-ce qu'on
a encore besoin de consulter voilà 150
citoyens tirés au sort je crois qu'il
faut pas en faire un manifeste faut pas
dire là je souscrire à ce que dit Jenny
il faut pas dire c'est une avancée
civilisationnelle faut dire c'est humain
c'est humain arrêtons de déblatérer sur
le sexe des anges c'est humain des gens
sur le mourants des gens sont fatigués
il y a toujours eu des gens qui
voulaient très âgés se suicider parce
qu'ils étaient à la Chambre des autres
ou parce qu'il sentait qu'il n'avaient
plus la possibilité de d'être d'avoir
leur indépendance en quelque sorte il
faut selon vous autorisé ces nouvelles
pratiques le le nazisme
qui vous parlez qui parlait Rachel
Rachel vous parlez pas vous êtes sage
non moi en fait effectivement je partage
sur les questions de loi qui existent
déjà par exemple dans la loi qui existe
il y a cette directive anticipée donc ça
veut dire que est-ce que vous autour de
la table vous avez rédigé votre la
directive anticipé non parce qu'on a du
mal à se projeter on a du mal à
anticiper notre propre mort donc il y a
des choses qui existent et je pense que
ça va être casuistique ça va être du cas
par cas en fait ces sujets là et
effectivement je pense que la loi est
suffisante et que l'application elle est
effectivement sur les dispositifs de la
fin de vie et l'accompagnement si on
doit avancer encore une fois c'est pas
du tout pour en faire un mantra en
disant que c'est le programme et qu'on
avance petit à petit sur ces sujets là
qui sont des sujets complexes qui sont
des sujets sur lesquels on peut même
avoir un avis différent d'une semaine à
l'autre d'un jour à l'autre ou en
fonction des circonstances de la vie en
revanche voilà que ce soit pas un sujet
qui soit réservé ou dont les familles
doivent s'encombrer ou gérer dans un
tête-à-tête avec un médecin qui est
quand même pas la meilleure solution que
ce soit un débat de société qui soit
posée peut-être que la conclusion une
fois que le débat sera éclairé c'est de
dire l'existant est suffisant il y a
suffisamment de situation on se rend
compte que voilà les gens se sentent
délaissés démunis donc l'idée c'est pas
de confier la mort à l'état mais en
revanche que l'État ne ferme pas les
yeux face à une réalité sociale ça me
semble aussi son rôle je vais quand même
vous montrer ce sondage
du mois de février 89% des Français
approuvent l'autorisation du recours au
suicide assisté 94% des Français
approuvent le recours à l'euthanasie
dans des cas de souffrance extrême et
incurable génie c'est une question de
liberté individuelle moi je trouve que
c'est évidemment si on me pose la
question est-ce que vous avez envie de
souffrir ou de mourir vous allez
répondre oui après les quand on pose
d'autres sondages la question est-ce que
vous voulez est-ce que vous voulez être
accompagné jusqu'au bout dans des champs
palliatifs les gens aussi sont
majoritaires et je pense que
effectivement oui poser la question en
disant est-ce que vous avez pas envie de
souffrir on est tous d'accord la
question vertigineuse qui se pose c'est
est-ce que on peut donner à la médecine
et à l'état le pouvoir de tuer c'est
quand même un renversement de la
médecine donc tu ne tueras point c'est
le c'est le enfin le serment
contre la volonté du patient oui
d'accord mais ça pose comme une question
parce que vous pouvez je dis pas que
j'ai la réponse c'est que entièrement
j'ai pas enfin je suis pas mais pensons
quand même à l'idée voilà même avec des
directeurs anticipées vous pouvez penser
à un moment a dans votre vie des choses
et puis changer d'avis et jusqu'au bout
changer d'avis avoir ne pas savoir et
c'est toute la question qu'on va poser
les malades d'Alzheimer parce que des
malades designers qui disent avant
d'avoir de tomber dans la dégénérescence
je veux je voudrais qu'on me tue et puis
et puis change d'avis et puis enfin
c'est très très compliqué alors c'est un
sujet qui va nous accompagner au moins
jusqu'au printemps que reste-t-il du
phénomène Eric Zemmour la semaine
dernière le parti reconquête fêtait
c'est un an et pour l'occasion un
meeting était organisé Porte de
Versailles à Paris 4000 militants ont
répondu à l'appel de leur chef écoutez
nous sommes nés il y a un an jour pour
jour à Villepinte
un an seulement et pourtant j'ai
l'impression d'avoir passé des années à
vos côtés un an seulement et que
d'aventure vécu que de chemin parcourus
nous avons connu des émotions un
descriptibles et des déceptions aussi
mais on le sait désormais quand on dit
le vrai quand on agit pour le bien on se
relève toujours 4000 militants Jonathan
4000 militants hors période électorale
qui peut faire ça encore aujourd'hui en
France
un noyau de ferveur autour d'Éric
Zemmour c'est une certitude je pense
qu'il y a quand même d'autres forces
politiques
c'est le même c'est le même aussi une
certaine manière la sanction des urnes
que ce soit la présidentielle ou que ce
soit la séquence législative derrière
elle a soldé en tout cas à court terme
sa capacité à transformer l'essai mais
donc je dis donc le parti n'est pas mort
reconquête n'est pas mort Éric Zeman
n'est pas mort c'est presque je enfin si
on interprète ce meeting
il est reparti dans une dans un rôle de
commentateur il est donc c'est la
bataille culturelle de de long cours il
est pas du tout acquis que il est un
acte 2 du d'une candidature d'Éric
Zemmour en 2027 on peut imaginer que le
RN type Jordan Bardella soit quelque
chose d'assez compliqué à gérer parce
qu'il y a il y a beaucoup de points
communs on peut imaginer qu'un vous
allez dire qu'un Laurent Wauquiez qui
prendrait la main sur la droite dans la
perspective de 2027 ça finit par faire
un espace qui est presque encore plus
petit
2022 donc le zemmourisme en revanche
c'est à dire ce que ça ce que ça a pesé
sur un certain nombre de débats publics
on a même plus l'entendre à certains
moments sur sur des sujets qu'on a
évoqué aujourd'hui évidemment que ça
continue à avoir de l'effet en gros je
pense que le zemmourisme pèse et que
Zemmour en opération survie génie sur
sur Maurice mais plutôt sur vraiment le
parti reconquête et Éric Zemmour
il faut relativiser son échec à la
présidentielle parce qu'effectivement
c'est un échec par rapport au sondage
qui lui est donné parfois à 15 18% etc
mais c'est quand même il est quand même
arrivé devant elle devant Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui sont des parties
qui sont enfin je crois l'initiative
vous savez voilà qui qui qui
cannibalisent et qui laisse peu de place
au petit parti et qui avait eu cette
union des droites dont il est arrivé ce
qui a réussi à faire Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à gauche mais je crois que dire que
c'était dire que ce qu'il a fait en 2022
c'est rien parce qu'il a fait 7 %, je
trouve que c'est un peu sévère parce que
il est quand même arrivé devant
n'oublions pas Valérie Pécresse et qu'il
a eu ses frais de campagne rembourser ce
qui n'empêche pas qu'il a fait
évidemment énormément d'erreurs il
continue à en faire puisque il prône
l'Union des droites tout en disant enfin
en insultant c'est les gens qui veulent
réconcilier en disant Marine Le Pen
c'est le socialisme et elle a l'air
c'est la molette si vous voulez vraiment
faire l'Union de la Droite il pourrait
dire par exemple Marine Le Pen elle a
les classes populaires
LR ils ont la compétence et les élus
réunions sur nous mais il est en fait il
veut marier des gens tout en les tout en
étant très sévère avec eux donc c'est il
me semble que stratégiquement c'est
peut-être pas ce qu'il faut faire
écouter un discours qui a été prononcé
lors de ce rassemblement le discours de
Guillaume Pelletier le vice-président de
reconquête Guillaume je suis français et
je suis patriote
je suis même un homme et un père
je suis blanc je suis chrétien je suis
hétérosexuel
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mal je roule au diesel
il faut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout fonction de
demande salut pierre amenez-les
[Musique]
Rachel se discours il incarne quoi
aujourd'hui dans la société française la
victimocratie on aurait pu effectivement
entendre les indigénistes dire
exactement la même chose je suis noir je
suis femme et je n'ai pas honte et je ne
demande pas pardon et c'est plutôt à la
France de me demander pardon enfin
c'est-à-dire que là en fait on voit à
quel point cette victimocratie imprègne
l'ensemble des partis politiques comme
si il fallait se oui ce victimiser pour
pour avoir une posture extrêmement forte
dans le paysage politique c'est pas du
Sandrine Rousseau mais on change les
mots et c'est la même chose en fait moi
ça m'inquiète beaucoup
parce que ça sert pas du tout la France
ça sert pas du tout nos préoccupations
et c'est surtout ce dialogue entre les
uns qui parle des noirs des Arabes
machin et des autres qui parlent des
blancs des gens qui parlent des
musulmans et les autres qui disent je
suis catholique ce n'est pas du tout
notre notre contrat
républicains en France mais bon
je suis assez d'accord je trouve que
c'est un peu ridicule de voilà d'être
identitaire à ce point-là et de et c'est
comme dire parler de franco-scie parce
qu'on parle de féminicide moi je suis
contre l'emploiée de mots je trouve que
parfois il y a voilà il y a un mimétisme
avec avec l'extrême gauche qui est
vraiment dommageable alors que par
ailleurs il y aura il y a un discours
qui peut qui est assez construit et
idéologique par ailleurs Christophe à
qui il parle
Eric Zemmour là en l'occurrence
il s'agit de surtout de je dirais de de
rassembler ces troupes qui l'ont un peu
abandonné depuis le rassemblement de
Villepinte il y a un an il y avait 10000
personnes il y en a 4000 donc il faut
qu'il essaie de de repeupler ses troupes
là si vous voulez si on voit un peu les
tiages de son organisation à l'heure
actuelle reconquête on est un peu dans
le même métier que les patriotes de
Florian Philippot c'est à dire un petit
groupe dynamique présent parce que il
est présent effectivement à la base il a
des militants qui sont un peu partout
dès qu'il y a un fait divers ils
accourent surtout que si ça concerne un
immigré il est il est donc très très
actif tout comme j'aurais Philippot
c'est refait une santé avec le mouvement
antivac en organisant des cortèges qui
étaient parfois des cortèges importants
et a réussi à maintenir quelque chose
maintenant je pense que Zemmour a raison
de s'inscrire sur le long terme parce
que en politique il y a que ça devrait
c'est-à-dire qu'on politique on met
beaucoup de temps à imposer une marque
regardez le Front National a mis
énormément de temps à imposer sa marque
politique pour un résultat plutôt
positif pour eux aujourd'hui et je pense
que Zemmour procède avec le même
intelligence pourrait-on dire tactique
et de dire il faut que je tienne le coup
et que je puisse m'imposer après la
grosse difficulté de Zemmour je ne
voyais parler je trouvais qu'il avait
des accents un peu un peu vieux jeu
c'est le fait qu'il je crois qu'il
manque de charisme c'est à dire que un
leader populiste ils ont pu l'appeler
comme ça il faut qu'il soit populaire il
faut qu'il soit porteur de quelque chose
de rassembleur en lui comme les sans
doute Marine Le Pen comme l'était
Jean-Marie Le Pen or Zemmour
physiquement il me fait penser un peu à
Bruno Maigret voyez c'est-à-dire c'est
la pile de l'extrême droite
40 ans je m'en excuse il avait plus il a
plus les mots une statue de polémiste de
journaliste il faisait des des
étincelles quand il était sur ses news
dans sa case dynamovible mais
aujourd'hui qu'il est de qu'il est dans
l'arène politique il lui manque sans
doute cette espèce de charisme qui fait
que les gens vont se comment dirais-je
essayer de lui ressembler vouloir être
comme lui en plus il a fait des choix
tactiques déplorables comme le fait par
exemple de d'aller faire son dernier
meeting de campagne au Trocadéro ce qui
est à la fois faire du parisianisme sera
lié à la classe bourgeoise parce que
tout sauf ce qu'il aurait dû faire s'il
avait voulu gagner des voix donc ça
c'est son problème Jonathan un pari Éric
Zemmour l'avenir politique d'Éric
Zemmour c'est quoi ça va être les
Européennes de 2024 pour tous les partis
en tout cas court terme c'est la
prochaine
élections
en Italie autour de Georges jameloni
c'est clairement ça voilà ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a et je pense oui effectivement
tacticien absolument nul donc paru un
ego surdimensionné par l'idée que le qui
domine de la tête et les épaules tous
ces politiques de droite à l'extrême
droite qu'il a quand même passé son
temps à mépriser quand il les observait
de près donc c'est quelqu'un qui est
quand même pas rassembleur pour un sou
qui se retrouve quand même je pense dans
une équation je le répète à droite et à
l'extrême droite qui est vraiment pas
facile qui va me mettre de plus en plus
compliqué il y a un après Marine Le Pen
même si elle sera sûrement candidate en
2027 qui se décide à travers Jordan
Bardella il a le temps il a même pas 30
ans et il va occuper un terrain
identitaire avec sûrement plus de de
capacités tactiques et de et de et de
vistack qui est avec Zemmour il y a
toujours personne derrière avec Zemmour
on pensait que Guillaume Pelletier c'est
le numéro de cette force là ça montre
quand même l'incurie de la force
collective
elle est encore une fois choisi le
mauvais cheval au mauvais moment quoi
un avenir politique en tout cas je pense
que l'union des droites en a et que
quand on voit ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays européens que ce soit
l'Italie que ce soit la Suède il cette
union des droits de se met en place et
je moi je pense en tout cas que elle a
elle a un avenir politique certains
parce que effectivement des forces comme
LR reconquête ne peuvent pas atteindre
le pouvoir par elle-même toute seule
comme chaque semaine on termine cette
émission par un top flop je vous pose à
chacun une question qui est très simple
quelle personnalité a marqué l'actualité
en bien ou en mal on va commencer avec
vous Jonathan c'est un double flop je
crois cette semaine pour vous il faut
dire les deux d'un coup là c'est ça on
peut perdue à ce moment là autant le jeu
premier flop qui est-ce non le premier
flop bah pour moi c'est côté insoumis
entre l'initiative un peu inattendu et
raté de Caroline Fiat sur la question de
de la réintégration des soignants non
donc ça chacun est libre après sur le
fond mais alors là on rentre dans la
popote parlementaire mais sur Public
Sénat ça a pris toujours on connaît ça
donc la niche RN qui reprenait la
proposition de loi qui avait été balayée
lors de la niche elle est fi donc du
coup le Caroline Fiat s'est dit qu'il y
avait pas un symbole absolument délétère
à venir se mettre sous l'ordre du jour
du RN elle s'est fait rappeler alors les
autres partenaires de la nuque en disant
on peut pas prenez le cordon le barrage
et tout ce qu'on veut et de l'autre côté
tomber dans un piège grossier bah le
deuxième flop c'est la droite on en a
parlé donc la droite qui est qui désigne
son nouveau son nouveau son PLR même si
la droite qu'est-ce que c'est
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'elle est
simplement à l'Élysée mais ça c'est un
autre débat non non les LR donc du coup
parti absolument majeur quand même de
ces dernières décennies dont aujourd'hui
la vie quotidienne est devenue la
quantité négligeable pour pour la
majorité des Français ouais on se rend
compte le match retaillo retaillos
Ciotti c'est c'est l'affiche et ça
laisse globalement c'est ça qu'on se
fait parce qu'il y a pas une proposition
qui est sortie de ce de cet affrontement
là et je pense qu'il la majorité de
Français qui est même pas au courant qui
se passe quelque chose
top top Catherine Meurice qui entre
l'Académie française avec ouais
exactement ouais bande dessinée avec un
humour grinçant qui en plus réinterroge
la philosophie etc je trouve que c'est
génial cette jeune femme qu'elle puisse
rentrer parmi les immortels et mon flop
évidemment Francky Vincent évidemment
non mais Francky Vincent oui ou
complètement Chevalier des Arts et des
Lettres nommé cette semaine
c'est à dire que au niveau des paroles
et de sérénées riches je peux vous en
citer une tu veux mon zizi oui oui oui
merci
évidemment cette pauvre basketteuse
américaine qui a enfin été libéré des
journées d'abord parce que la pauvre
elle était vraiment prise en otage dans
un conflit ou évidemment qu'elle
devenu correspondait pas enfin elle
s'est retrouvé là-dedans et puis en plus
je trouve que c'est la preuve qu'il y a
encore un dialogue même s'il est minime
un dialogue de guerre froide entre la
Russie et les États-Unis alors dans le
négatif c'est la guerre froide qui
revient comme si on était en 1952 et
dans le positif ça prouve qu'il y a
quand même un dialogue qui se maintient
entre l'Est et l'Ouest si je puis dire
et donc un espoir de paix peut-être un
jour donc ça c'est le top ça c'est le
top et le flop c'est ça reste en Russie
c'est le hasard c'est les gens qui
retirent des livres LGBT ou je sais pas
quoi de leur librairie parce que ça
témoigne encore de cette éternelle
phénomène propre à notre époque qui est
celui de l'autocensure c'est-à-dire
qu'on attend même pas que ça soit l'état
qui vous interdisent de faire quelque
chose on le fait avant on le fait tout
de suite et même on le fait même si
l'État ne demande pas il fut une époque
où la censure venait d'en haut
aujourd'hui apparemment la censure vient
d'en bas c'est dommage
c'est à vous votre top et votre
top alors oui c'est un TOP la Chine qui
abandonne enfin qui abandonne
ces dispositifs anticoïdes
sous pression de la population et enfin
enfin la Chine lâche un peu de l'est
parce que c'est absolument épouvantable
la manière dont les pauvres chinois
vivent depuis plusieurs années et je
pense que ça dit quelque chose sur sur
l'échec en fait de la Chine à imposé une
forme de soft power c'est à dire qu'ils
sont très très forts sur la technologie
c'est une sorte de techno dictature
extrêmement puissante mais ils
n'arrivent pas à voilà faire valoir leur
modèle dans les années 60-70 la Chine
était extrêmement autoritaire avec Mao
mais elle met toutes les élites
occidentales étaient converties au Moïse
mais là c'est pas la même chose et mon
flop c'est pour les étudiants de
Sciences Po qui ont qui ont poussé à la
démission leur prof de danse qui
voulaient continuer à faire danser les
les garçons et les filles en couple et
que donc ils l'ont poussé à la démission
elle a refusé de changer la terminologie
homme-femme pour me dire leader follower
et donc soutien à cette prof et je
trouve ça va un dit long sur cette
espèce de mentalité studentine qui
consiste à demander au cours de
s'adapter aux étudiants plutôt que de
suivre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
tous les cas de l'avoir participé merci
à vous d'avoir votre écran on me dit
dans l'oreillette que vous êtes de plus
en plus nombreux à nous regarder à nous
regarder et à nous revoir en replay et
en podcast merci à tous on se retrouve
au mois de janvier d'ici là prenez soin
de vous et bonne fête à tous
[Musique]